se pourrait-il 4 trop intelligent nous
rendent bête
c'est en tout cas l'idée que je vais
essayer de défendre dans cette vidéo
préparez-vous génériques
[Musique]
alors d'abord il faut qu'on s'entende
sur ce qu'on appelle l'intelligence
l'intelligence ce n'est pas la culture
si vous préférez c'est pas parce qu'on a
lu des livres ou qu'on à bac +5 qu'on
est intelligent savoir qui était le dieu
de la guerre chez les romains savoir
combien il y ades dans le corps humain
ça c'est de la culture ça montre qu'on a
étudié et qu'on a une bonne capacité de
mémorisation mais sur le plan
intellectuel c'est pas différent de
connaître la liste des pokémon ça peut
aider au trivial pursuit mais ça fait
pas nous quelqu'un d'intelligent donc
l'intelligence ce n'est pas la mémoire à
moins de penser qu'un disque dur soit
intelligent alors l'intelligence c'est
quoi au sens premier l'intelligence
c'est la capacité à comprendre les
choses par le recours au raisonnement
c'est l'aptitude à mettre en oeuvre une
réflexion pour résoudre un problème ou
pour expliquer une situation ce qui
signifie déjà qu'il ne faut pas
confondre intelligent et intellectuelle
un bûcheron qui si le tronc d'un arbre
de sorte que l'arbre tombe dans une
certaine direction un boxeur qui analyse
les déplacements de son adversaire pour
le coincer dans les cordes c'est
l'intelligence ce qui serait stupide ce
serait de courir après son adversaire
pour lui porter des coups sans réfléchir
ou de scier l'arbre sans se poser la
question de savoir où il va atterrir
l'intelligence c'est donc une capacité
de projection et d'anticipation qui
passe par l'analyse des paramètres en
présence c'est l'aptitude à établir des
connexions entre les causes et les
effets qui va nous permettre de prévoir
ce qui va arriver en fonction de ce qui
est arrivé ou de ce que je m'apprête à
faire si je vends mon lit le matin et
que le soir je me demande où je vais
dormir c'est que manifestement je n'ai
pas fait preuve d'intelligence puisque
je n'ai pas anticipé la conséquence
directe de mon acte je n'ai pas établi
la relation logique entre l'événement à
et l'événement b et ça ça nous conduit à
une deuxième définition de
l'intelligence qui est le sens de
l'adaptation
on peut reprendre l'exemple du bûcheron
que j'utilisais tout à l'heure si le
bûcheron sait dans quelle direction va
tomber l'arbre il va pouvoir adapter son
comportement à cette information par
exemple en évitant resté planté juste en
dessous pour après chacun fait comme il
veut
comme pour le sens de l'anticipation le
sens de l'adaptation peut prendre
différentes formes selon les contextes
par exemple si j'analyse dont les
parents via de mourir oui j'ai décidé de
mettre l'ambiance et que je le raconte
que mes parents sont en train de passer
leur deuxième lune de miel aux bahamas
à ce moment là ce que je dis n'est pas
intelligent au sens où c'est inapproprié
à la situation je n'anticipe pas les
conséquences de mes paroles sur celui
qui est en face de moi je ne prends pas
en compte sa situation émotionnelle
intelligence est un phénomène pro
ils forment et l'erreur serait de
réduire l'intelligence à sa version
logique et mathématique
le qi quotient intellectuel est un outil
qui permet de mesurer l'intelligence
logique et dans la culture occidentale
c'est généralement le cui qui sert de
référence à la mesure de l'intelligence
mais on peut avoir 150 de cuillé être un
parfait abruti sur le plan émotionnel
relationnelles ou manuel il ya des gens
qui sont capables de calculer
mentalement la racine cubique d'un
nombre à six chiffres mais qui sont de
véritables estropiés sur le plan
émotionnel ou qui ne saurait pas se
servir d'un tournevis
si je rencontre quelqu'un pour la
première fois et que je lui dis que sa
tronche ne me revient pas je lui dis
peut-être ce que je pense mais sur le
plan relationnel je me tire une balle
dans le pied puisque je lui envoie un
message d'hostilité alors qu'il ne m'a
rien fait et ça de toute évidence ce
n'est pas être intelligent donc je vous
ai fait une petite sélection de livres
sur la question de l'intelligence que
vous trouverez en description de cette
vidéo
j'ai choisi des livres relativement
accessible pour que chacun puisse
piocher dans ce qui l'intéresse
que ce soit sur la question du qi ou sur
celle des intelligences multiples qui
est un concept que je vous invite à
découvrir si vous ne connaissez pas donc
on a bien compris que l'intelligence
c'était d'abord une capacité de
projection et d'adaptation à un contexte
mais ça ça ne répond pas directement à
la question initiale qui était de savoir
en quoi être trop intelligent peut-il
rendre bête parce qu'a priori l'excès
d'intelligence n'a jamais été un
problème
on n'a jamais entendu quelqu'un nous
dire oh là là attention tu es trop
intelligent la forêt qui lève le pied
bien vous allez voir que ce n'est pas
aussi simple que ça en a l'air
l'ex et d'intelligence c'est quand
l'intelligence n'est plus investi dans
la résolution de problèmes existants
mais dans la création de problème
artificiel
l'excellent intelligence c'est lorsque
nous analysons les choses non pas parce
que la situation l'exigé
mais parce que nous avons un besoin
irrépressible de tout analyser c'est
lorsque par notre pensée nous
complexifiant inutilement les choses
juste pour le plaisir d'avoir des
problèmes à résoudre à ce moment là
l'intelligence n'est donc plus un moyen
de résoudre des problèmes mais un moyen
de les entretenir voire de les amplifier
juste pour satisfaire notre besoin de
réfléchir et réfléchir sur un problème
qui n'existe pas ce n'est pas
l'intelligence c'est le contraire de
l'intelligence puisque l'intelligence
sert à résoudre donc ici quand je parle
d'un excès d'intelligence je parle en
fait d'une hypertrophie de l'intellect
je parle d'un excès de l'activité
mentale qui se fait au détriment de la
compréhension à partir du moment où
réfléchir nez
mais un moyen de comprendre mais devient
une finalité en soi à partir du moment
où analysé n'est plus quelque chose
d'utile
mais un besoin incontrôlable on sort de
notre licence on devient une machine à
penser
il y à des personnes très intelligentes
qui sont capables d'élaborer des
scénarios intellectuelle extrêmement
sophistiqué mais l'ennui c'est que ces
scénarios ne correspondent à aucune
nécessité pratique ce sont des
labyrinthes sans issue qui ne débouchent
sur aucune solution et le problème c'est
que pendant qu on s'épuise à fabriquer
des scénarios manteau on ne vit plus
l'hypertrophie de l'intellect nos rangs
complètement aveugle aux évidences un
peu comme si l'évidence c'était quelque
chose de trop simple pour satisfaire
notre esprit on ne voit pas des choses
qui saute aux yeux de n'importe qui tout
simplement parce qu'on tient à avoir des
problèmes à résoudre et que ne plus
avoir de problèmes ce serait comme cessé
d'exister
on cherche pas à résoudre on cherche à
avoir quelque chose à résoudre justement
pour ne pas le résoudre
c'est ce que j'appelle l'intelligence
masochistes c'est l'intelligence qui se
bat contre elle-même parce qu'encore une
fois créée de toutes pièces un problème
qui n'existe pas ou extrapoler un
problème qui pourrait être résolue de
manière simple ce n'est pas être
intelligent c'est juste travailler à se
faire souffrir et à se rendre malheureux
lien auteurs qui s'appelle écart tollé
qui parle lui de la pensée compulsive
là encore vous trouverez tous les liens
dans la description la pensée compulsif
c'est quand on ne parvient pas à
interrompre la pensée c'est quand on a
besoin de se poser les questions et
qu'on tourne en boucle dans nos schémas
mentaux
sans jamais parvenir à se reposer la
pensée compulsif c'est un phénomène
involontaire dont on n'est pas forcément
conscient mais dont on peut prendre
conscience à partir du moment où on
devient le témoin intérieur de nos
pensées écartelé explique que dans cette
course effrénée du mental dans ce
travail de remue-ménage permanent qui
fait qu'on va toujours être insatisfaits
on s'épuise et on se perd le penseur
compulsif c'est à dire presque tout le
monde vit dans un état d'apparence
division dans un monde déraisonnablement
complexe où foisonnent perpétuellement
problèmes et conflits
un monde qui reflète l'incessante
fragmentation du mans
le philosophe français des cartes a cru
avoir découvert la vérité la plus
fondamentale quand il fit sa célèbre
déclaration
je pense donc je suis il venait en fait
de formuler l'erreur la plus
fondamentale celle d'assimiler la pensée
à l'être et l'identité à la pensée la
pensée compulsif c'est ce besoin que
nous avons de nous infliger une torture
mentale alors que personne ne nous le
demandent
c'est schopenhauer qui disait que
l'homme était le seul animal capable
d'être malheureux parce que c'est le
seul animal qui possède un intellect
autrement dit ce le seul animal qui se
pose des questions on souffre parce
qu'on a des questions sans réponses et
pour conjurer cette souffrance pour la
faire disparaître il n'y a que deux
possibilités soit on trouve la réponse à
nos questions
soit on arrête de se poser des questions
l'intelligence nous rend bête à partir
du moment où elle sert uniquement à nous
rendre malheureux et je répète souvent
cette phrase qu'on trouve aussi ces
écarts tall est bien souvent le chemin
st
c'est nous qui sommes compliqués la
pensée est un outil formidable à partir
du moment où on la contrôle
elle devient notre ennemi à partir du
moment où c'est elle qui nous contrôle
merci d'avoir suivi cet épisode
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner et de
partager la vidéo sur vos réseaux
sociaux
rejoignez moi sur facebook le précepteur
je suis également présent sur instagram
et comme à chaque fois un grand merci
aux ti peur pour leur soutien
indéfectible
je vous dis à bientôt pour un prochain
épisode
[Musique]